[Musique]
depuis le début de l'épidémie de kobe 19
touchant la france l'ancien champion de
tennis yannick noah a décidé de prendre
les choses avec le sourire et de
proposer à ses fans un contenu léger et
souriant pour détendre l'atmosphère
et si jusqu'ici ses parodies et
publications décalé avait fait
l'unanimité
cette fois ci la star a probablement
fait la blague de trop sur son compte
instagram
à tel point que l'interprète de saga
africa s'est empressé de supprimer la
vidéo pas son retour très négatif sur
son sketch il faut dire que yannick noah
a pris le risque de rire sur un sujet
pour le moins périlleux alors que des
milliers de personnes sont hospitalisées
dans le monde en insuffisance
respiratoire à cause du coronavirus
l'ancien sportif s'est amusé à jouer un
patient qui serait en train de recevoir
une perfusion de ricard je compte
beaucoup sur son père fut une petite
saynète qui a grandement diviser les
internautes si certains ont trouvé cela
amusant prétextant qu'il faut rire de
tout pour d'autres il s'agit là d'un
manque de respect pour ceux qui
aujourd'hui essaye de se battre coûte
que coûte contre le virus ainsi que pour
les familles des victimes
alors parodie de yannick noah à
l'hôpital choquer ou pas choquer alors
choqué ou pas choquer yannick noah qu'un
sophie cost nazima sociaux
non mais moi je alors je comprends le
projet c'est-à-dire qu'ils essaient de
faire rire les gens et c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt bienvenu de sa part mais là
pour moi une vraie maladresse voilà sur
le la mise en scène du truc on peut pas
se mettre en scène dans un état où on
est à moitié mourant avec une perfusion
ce que c'est le quotidien 'aujourd'hui
de milliers de personnes dans les
hôpitaux dans les services de
réanimation donc effectivement line est
complètement à côté de la plaque
et pourtant dieu sait que je suis pas
pour la censure je suis vraiment pour
rire de tout mais je pense qu'à une
vraie maladresse et pu peut-être un
problème de timing c'est peut-être pas
le moment là il aurait put à vizag sur
le riz cas que c'est vrai qu'il ya pas
mal de gens qui picolent en ce moment et
ce après lingolo mais d'une tête d'une
autre manière la mise en scène est un
peu bord remo ouais c'est ça c'est un
peu sais pas je parlais jusqu'à jusqu'à
choquer je suis pas choqué c'est juste
que c'est pas drôle en fait c'est
jusqu'à quand elle a dit sophie c'est
pas le moment il ya le timing avec des
élus rica s'est pas y en a qui vont
trouver ça drôle qui vont dire cette vie
bournois moi je ne sais pas rires mais
je suis pas choqué puisque ça ça me fait
pas rire valérie bénaïm je suis sûr que
valérie a choqué la connaît oui oui oui
moi je suis choqué s'il s'est
complètement plantée à l'heure ou à des
gens en terre
membre de leur famille à l'heure où les
gens peuvent pas aller assister aux
enterrements où il y en a qui sont en
train de se battre il ya vraiment des
gens qui vivent des moments tragiques
voilà donc il faut penser à ces gens là
qui aujourd'hui sont dans une vraie
souffrance ils peuvent même pas la
compagnie jusqu'au bout ce qu'ils aiment
franchement il ya ce n'était pas ce que
c'est pas drôle cette foire et c'est à
côté de la plaque vraiment mérité chez
vous est-ce que vous avez été choqué par
la vidéo de yannick noah je vous en
montrer notamment d'avoir l'avis de
drainer également deux rennais et notre
vidéo qui a fait le buzz de victoire il
a posté sur instagram sa méthode pour
fabriquer son masque pour ça il a besoin
d'une chaussette et du papier toilette
regarde salut tout le monde écoute j'ai
un petit truc à partager avec vous ça va
donner
je vais essayer l'essayer vu ça sur
internet c'est pas mal une paire de
chaussettes propres si possible
on prend une voie là tu coupes voie au
niveau du talon ensuite battu prend fin
un peu tout cela ce moment chypre a dupé
tu suis le grand dedans et puis après
ils écoutent après je sais pas on verra
après tu vois ton masque et tu peux y
aller ça c'est pas mal franchement c'est
pas mal après après moi je vous demande
un peu d'indulgence aussi pour tous les
gens qui font des vidéos j'ai cru que
sur un stade on peut pas toujours être
drôle ligne rien voilà après on tente
des choses il essaie de changer
voilà les les idées des gens heureux
n'est que temporaire ceux qui sont
choqués je suis persuadé que parce que
moi j'ai un turban et le children métier
c'est que ça à [ __ ]
c'était cette photo l'avait la perfusion
je les ai peut-être 300 fois et chaque
fois partagé deux emplois là était 400
fois je vois pas qui c'est qui ce trouve
parce que bon d'accord on va pas tout
dramatiser heureusement il ya des gens
comme ça qui qui forment quelques
petites rides moi je vois pas pourquoi
je serais choqué de sa jeune est venu
quatre fois en un mois que cette photo
mais avec d'autres personnes les
inconnues et que tout le monde a sa part
dans la gueule